So here I'd like to start making some observations about what we kind of
just did.
We did it in very kind of a specific step by step way.
But we want to come up with some general methods to help us
understand how to do this.
Well simply put, what we did was we took a small image.
So, a small three by three, and we rubbed it over a bigger image.
And when we rubbed it, basically we did some calculations at each and
every center point relating to this point and that point.
And we put that in a newer data structure.
The new value, which basically took the information from this three by three,
plus this three by three and replacing this value.
So let's see what we can come up with as a general approach to looking at that.
Just to help us with terminology, and I used that term again in a previous
slides too, is imagine this to be a function h ij, just a small matrix.
And we'll refer to this as a kernel image.
This kernel image in this instance is a three by three.
And the area around each original pixel is with the one that we actually,
the neighborhood is around one pixel.
In this one, my neighborhood is of the size one.
So my k is equal to 1.
Again, k equal to 1 allows me to create a three by three neighborhood.
I can imagine if the k was equal to 2,
we would be able to generate a five by five neighborhood, and so on.
again, the size of the neighborhood is important because,
again, you want to use that to generalize our observation and
how we go about creating these types of filters.
And now basically looking at that equation what you can say is well,
the window size will therefor be 2k plus 1.
k was 1, 2k plus 1 equals 3.
If k is equal to 2,
2k plus 1, is equal to 5.
And so on.
So this is an important, parameter that we need to remember is,
we need to always remember the neighborhood size, and
this will allow us to start figuring out the size of a kernel.
In this case, our kernel is 3 by 3.
Again, we will see that many of times these kernels will be rather big.
Or again, depending on how big a neighborhood we want to smooth over we will
employ different types of sizes of these images.
Important to note that in doing this kind stuff we are basically again taking
a three by three kernel, applying it to a three by three window here, and
then move one after the other.
And that's what I mean by rubbing an image over,
rubbing a kernel over a bigger image.